what's going on guys this is rob and
darth vader shows up and spiderman no
way home and kills everybody spoiler
alert just messing around we are back
with another installment of beyond omega
level where we discuss the most powerful
characters in comics and today we are
talking about one of the biggest
villains both in terms of popularity and
in terms of just sheer power to come
along in several years no the god of the
symbiotes so null was created by donnie
cates and ryan stegman and first
appeared in venom number three in 2018.
now to understand null's origin you
first have to understand that the marvel
multiverse has existed in multiple
incarnations that have gone through the
cycles of destruction and rebirth now if
you pick up a marvel comic today the
story will almost certainly take place
in the eighth incarnation of the
multiverse but null has existed since
the destruction of the sixth incarnation
now after the sixth iteration of the
multiverse was destroyed null existed in
the void of nothingness that was left in
its wake until the celestials reformed
the multiverse into its seventh version
now angry that he basically been woken
up from a state of perpetual darkness
null forges the first symbiote a weapon
known as the all-black necro sword which
he uses to kill a celestial so right off
the bat we know we're dealing with a
ridiculously serious threat just by
virtue of the fact that he was able to
kill one of the most powerful beings in
the universe now the other celestials
end up punishing noel by banishing him
to a void like prison where he continues
working on all black now eventually null
uses the sword to go on a killing spree
taking out various gods throughout the
universe until he is eventually
incapacitated after a battle against an
unnamed god and loses all black to gore
the god butcher who i've also done a
beyond omega level video on who's going
to be amazing if the marvel cinematic
universe takes him from the comics and
throws him in there and he has any
semblance of the power that he has from
the comics now when null is awakened he
creates an army of symbiotes that share
a hive mind under his control and these
are basically the same race that the
venom symbiote and all of its offspring
belong to but once they're able to rebel
against null the symbiotes create a
planet and imprison null inside of it
and so null would remain in the prison
for thousands of years before being
awakened once more this time when shield
began conducting experiments on one of
the first symbiotes to make its way to
earth and yet again when a cult devoted
to worshipping him resurrects cletus
cassidy the host of the carnage symbiote
now cletus then collects the codices of
all the former symbiote hosts and
manages to fully resurrect null who
comes to earth and battles basically
every superhero on the planet during the
king and black storyline in 2020 and
null is one of the most powerful
villains to come out of mama comics for
the last several years and is probably
one of the strongest villains in marvel
comics period which is why it took
basically every superhero working
together to take him on and also why
they weren't really able to put up much
of a resistance against this guy so null
is an immortal being that has existed
for billions of years he has superhuman
strength invulnerability and a
regenerative healing factor that heals
nearly every injury instantaneously his
primary power is that he can use his
ability to control the living abyss that
made up the void he once inhabited to
create a seemingly unlimited number of
symbiotes and can control them through
the hive mind that they all share now
some of the symbiotes normal has created
have been extremely powerful especially
all black which as we said earlier was
able to kill a celestial and it was also
able to take over and control the silver
surfer which is an extremely impressive
feat given how powerful the silver
surfer is and null was also able to
create enough symbiotes to encase the
earth in a symbiote dome that prevented
any sunlight from getting through now as
if killing a celestial was not enough
evidence of how powerful this guy is we
have several other feats that we can
look at to get an idea of just how
ridiculously op null was so during an
encounter with the silver surfer the two
battle until the surfer realizes he has
no hope of defeating nol in a desperate
attempt to avoid defeat the surfer uses
every bit of his power cosmic reserves
to create a sun whose energy he will
harness to temporarily incapacitate null
but remarks that he knows null will not
die and will return and just thinking
about how impressive that is the power
cosmic has allowed the silver surfer to
do some pretty incredible things without
exhausting all of his reserves so the
fact that he needed every bit of it just
to temporarily stop this guy is pretty
insane now on another occasion null
battled thor while he had both the power
cosmic and the thor force which are two
of the most powerful forces in the
marvel universe and he had these at his
disposal and even with both of these
forces as well as his hammer mjolnir
thor is no match for null even when thor
manages to remove null's lower jaw with
his hammer knoll's able to heal and then
run thor through with the all block and
it's also around this time that null is
able to awaken multiple celestials which
he's able to enslave and control with
his symbiotes which is just one more
example of his ridiculous power and as
if this weren't enough
nola was able to easily dispatch one of
the strongest characters in marvel
comics the century now i just did a
beyond omega level video on this guy so
if you want to know more about him you
can go check that out but he's basically
marvel's version of superman and is
actually probably more powerful than
superman and null literally rips him in
half like a sheet of paper and absorbs
his evil counterpart the void to make
himself stronger now this was a pretty
shocking moment when it happened because
no one had ever been able to do anything
like that to this century before and it
was one of the first things that we saw
null do when he arrived on earth so it
really sent a message that this guy was
like a serious universal threat now like
i said earlier all the heroes on earth
were basically useless in trying to stop
this guy and he seemed to be poised to
defeat all of them and conquer the world
until the one thing that could defeat
him entered the battle which was the
unipower and this is of course an aspect
of the enigma force a sentient deity of
life that has existed since the
celestials created the seventh iteration
of the multiverse but as a sentient
energy source the unipower bonds itself
to a host in a similar fashion to the
way that null symbiotes do and when the
unit power chooses a person to bond with
that host becomes captain universe which
is an extremely powerful cosmic entity
devoted to protecting life throughout
the universe now as it turns out the
enigma force being a god of life is in
direct opposition to no the living
embodiment of darkness and the void so
after dominating all of earth's heroes
null is eventually defeated when the
unit power merges with eddie brock who
then becomes captain universe and
seemingly kills null and of course all
this takes place in the king and black
storyline which i have a video on right
so you guys are welcome to go check that
out if you want to know about the whole
king and black event it's amazing but i
think we've done a pretty good job of
covering exactly what it is that null is
capable of and why he should definitely
be considered beyond omega level but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section let me know if you guys
think we should do anybody else thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you guys later
peace